so so so what I'm going to talk about
the general issue of when randomness the
ability to make random decisions by an
algorithm actually speeds up computation
so I think like when people first
studied randomness the following would
be like considered a moderate view so
you could like ask some quantitative
questions about when does randomness
help speed up computation and here speed
up I mean by more than a polynomial
factor so there may be lots of times
when randoms gives you a sub linear
algorithm when you have and you can't
possibly come up with a sub linear
deterministic algorithm because you
don't have time to read the whole input
but I'm talking about like standard
algorithms where you're given the whole
you're able to read the whole input and
when we we don't like distinguish
between N and N squared at the moment we
will do that we did that an hour ago and
we will do that in the future but not
for this talk okay so um so you could
think that you know you look at does for
every heart problem does randomness help
on lots of inputs that's kind of an
extreme point of view every hard problem
it helps on a huge number of inputs
that's very impossible right see
everyone agrees anyone would say on
every hard problem that you imagine you
know that's hard for deterministic
algorithms randomness is going to help
okay we don't know yeah but you know too
much okay so we do have improved that
but it seems very impossible right so
but it could well even that it would
help on a few instances of you know
worst-case instances of every hard
problem that seems somewhat impossible
and you know and maybe I'm saying like
actually help on no instances you know
there might be hard problems where
randomness never helps I'm guys
SATA probably it might be in some
instances of hard problems where
randomness never helps okay on the other
hand you know there are a few
specialized hard problems where you know
maybe randomness helps on many instances
it would seem like okay at least for the
worst-case instances randomness might
help for some problems okay and you know
and so if you think that then maybe it's
unlikely that randomness never helps
super polynomial II for any hard problem
for any hard problem this seems like a
moderate point of view so as Ryan was
saying we don't know how to rule out
extreme points of view about randomness
versus time the one point of view we
know how to rule out is the moderate
point of view we know that's why I
actually isn't true so okay and i hope
to like give you a sketch of why we can
rule that out as a possibility before
before the end of ba before the end of
the hour okay but um he's a moderate you
both have double negation I'm really not
sure what the claim is okay anyway he
will I'll be vague about that and then
I'll give you a formal statement at the
end okay so um okay so what kind of
problems might randomness help with so
here are a couple problems that you know
we're that actually got a lot of first
attracted attention of algorithm
designers to the potential for
randomness so one is prime ality testing
so that was like the big killer app for
randomized algorithms for many years
rabin and solavei straße in the 70s both
came up with randomized algorithms to
test whether a number is prime in
polynomial time
and it was until the the this millennium
that agrawal Kyle and sexina came up
with an equivalent deterministic
algorithm there was a lot of work in the
middle that I'm slurring over okay but
we now know that it's also possible to
compute prime ality deterministically on
the other hand there's this other
problem that came up around the same
time maybe a little bit less famous but
has a lot of applications called
polynomial identity testing where you're
given some kind of algebraic identity
expressed as an algebraic circuit and
you want to know whether that identity
is actually valid so this is actually
used to do things like test equivalence
of branching programs as valentin was
telling me about the other day so or
reminding me of so this was came first
there was like Schwartz ippo demillo and
lipton came up with this idea again in
the 70s and D randomizing this algorithm
is still a subject of a lot of very
interesting ongoing research but it's
only being doing randomized partially
and for very special cases and here's a
kind of universal problem 4d
randomization ok if is complete for the
promised version of the probabilistic
class so it's complete for promise bpp
and I'm going to try to not define that
but hopefully people know what I mean so
bpp means that you have a bounded error
probabilistic machine promise VPP is say
okay well we relax the the notion you
don't have to be bounded are everywhere
just whenever you're not we're not
responsible for what happens
problem Center yes yeah so the a good
point so but in some sense if we could
given a circuit in it's very easy just
through random sampling given a circuit
to estimate the probability that the
circuit accepts a random input to within
a certain error bound like point point
one but it's not clear how to do this
deterministically okay so um so why am i
why are we talking about the
randomization in this workshop well say
if you look at this problem it's of a
familiar type it's a it's a kind of meta
algorithmic problem an algorithm that
takes another algorithm namely the
circuit as its input and has to compute
something about what this input
algorithm actually does what language or
problem this input problem solves okay
so another of the another meta problem
that's kind of similar is satisfiability
given the circuit does it ever output
one ok so so a large thema of relatively
recent research has been that these meta
algorithm problems meta algorithmic
problems provide a connection between
upper bounds and lower amounts between
proving that especially in non-uniform
models like circuits problems are
difficult and coming up with algorithms
for other problems and here I'm going to
steal sort of an intuition for why
there's a connection between these
problems for from Ryan who explained it
to me as follows ok so we can improving
a lower bound you're trying to show that
whatever circuit you're given as input
there's an in some sense fails to solve
a problem ok that circuit fails
in algorithm design you're trying to
show that for every input the algorithm
succeeds fail succeeds circuit input the
connection is in a meta algorithm the
input to the algorithm is also a circuit
so if we can do a little flip and say
the algorithm succeeds when the input
fails to solve a problem then then we
can connect in a formal sense the
algorithm design problem to the to the
lower bound problem okay and and so I
think do you rent the context of D
randomization was the first one where
that connection was made precise and and
it's also the ryans later work does the
same thing for the satisfiability
problem and related problems but it also
builds on the connections that were made
through D randomization so I wanna today
and going on through the week review the
connections between in India and the
context of D randomization between the
lower bounds at the algorithm design
problems that come up by viewing the
randomization as a meta meta algorithm
problem and the two on this list okay
that sort of qualify as meta algorithmic
problems are the circuit value
approximation problems sort of obviously
a meta problem but also this polynomial
identity testing problem is a meta
problem of a meta algorithmic problem of
a different kind because the input is an
identity and the identity is expressed
as an algebraic formula or circuit so
any questions so far about the the high
level
okay and so what I want to do today and
the rest of this hour is talk about how
we use lower bounds to design algorithms
and this was the historically the first
the first direction first kind of
connection between the lower bound
problem and the algorithm design problem
that was that was discovered way back in
the 80s some version by Yau and then
later by Nissan and wig gerson so
revised and revitalized the connection
and then later in the week tomorrow
we're going to talk about this other
direction and then we're going to
Thursday talk about how you use that to
prove one of the lemmas that Ryan's
going to need in his work the easy
witness lemma and then Friday go back to
the polynomial identity testing problem
and show similar connections for that
problem
okay so um
and I'm going to do you know i'm going
to try to get through a lot of material
today and the way i'm going to do that
is by waving my hands vigorously i'm
going to tell you sort of what types of
things have been done but not give you
the details of how they've been done and
yeah so what's been done why it was done
not so much how and no proofs so
so we need to sort of to connect these
dots we need to make we're saying the
circuits for the so here we're going to
look at exactly this circuit
approximation problem and show if we've
got a sufficiently strong lower bound
for circuit complexity that gives us an
algorithm for the circuit approximation
problem and hence that circuit since
that circuit approximation problem can
code pretty much any randomized decision
problem it gives us an algorithm for
pretty much any randomized decision
problems okay so um in the way we need
to do that to connect the dots say okay
the input to the algorithm design
problem is a circuit okay and we need to
say have that circuit fail to compute to
solve one problem if and only if our
algorithm succeeds so we need to design
an algorithm so that when it's given a
circuit as input the our algorithm is
going to work precisely when the circuit
fails to solve a problem and here's the
type of problem that that we want our
circuit our input circuits to have to
fail and that's the randomness
distinguishing problem so the randomness
distinguishing problem
is we have some kind of map is define
relative to some kind of generator G
that takes in an input that i'm going to
call on say n sub G and outputs a much
longer string T a much longer T bit
straight in the randomness
distinguishing problem is the the
problem of given Z is it G of X for
random acts
or is it a random is it itself randomly
chosen so to make it precise you just
say is it in the range of this generator
but we're looking at a particular
distribution of inputs to make it hard
on that distribution by saying we're
either picking fifty percent of the time
we're picking it at random from the you
know as a random G of X and fifty
percent we're just picking it at random
in the circuit it has to distinguish say
which one of these two possibilities is
happening so key is yeah so the say like
the the G randomness distinguishing
problem is for fixed G say which which
of these two possibilities so
the
so the algorithm say we've got the
algorithm for the circuit circuit
approximation problem sort of the the
universal form of the algorithm based on
this heart the hardness of this problem
is to simply run through all X in 0 1 to
the n sub G and compute C of G of X and
i'll put the fraction that equal to 1
this is this clear so remember that
we're this is the algorithm for the
approximate what did I call it what's
the standard name you know this circuit
yes circuit approximation problem so the
input to the problem so the problem this
algorithm is trying to solve is given a
circuit see estimate the fraction of
inputs of random inputs on which is true
deterministically is that clear so C is
the input to the algorithm so the
algorithm on input C does the following
and you have to pick you have to pick so
here you you know to figure out what the
right value of n is you have to say well
this circuit has t bit to let t be the
number of input bits to your circuit
input circuit and then figure out n sub
G as a function invert the function that
map's n sabji to tea and that's how many
random bits pseudo-random bit that you
need for the algorithm so this algorithm
runs in time 2 to the n sub G time the
time times the time to compute e plus
the time to compute C
but the the time to compute see is you
know to evaluate see on an input is
going to be negligible compared to the
other factors in every every interesting
application I'm still confused okay
right so the cap problem is is so the
cap problem saying if we fail to solve
the what we're trying to say is the
algorithm fails solves the solves the
the algorithm remember okay so let me
look at this this analogy the algorithm
succeeds on an input circuit to solve
the cat problem if and only if the input
circuit fails to solve the
distinguishing problem so Alec has
access to so let's do it when we just
I'm just going to write that to write
that down in big letters okay so al of C
succeeds
to solve half of see if and only if C
fails to solve the G randomness
distinguishing the problem yeah so maybe
like I'll put out each that access to a
library of instances of Jeannie right
that's right so I think this is okay so
I mean we could go through it and
quantify this but I think it's fairly
clear so there's there's the formal
connection there's the exact connection
that we wanted that the lower bound
success you know the lower the algorithm
design succeeds on every input if and
only if that input fails to solve a
related problem yes
yeah it's a probabilistic statement so
so I so say so basically i should say if
she fails to solve this with say less
than like ninety-five percent success
probability when you can fax fails to be
mad yeah yeah so i need to you know so
like fails it so if the more that C
fails the better the estimate we have
here I put an arbitrary number point 1
as our criterion for success here and so
you get some other arbitrary number here
that will be our criterion for failure
here
ok
okay maybe I think it's Morgan it's
going to be more like fifty five percent
just close to half way I defined it
hopefully this this is anyone never seen
some ideas like this before is maybe
restating them in a different way okay
go hopefully this is this is general
familiar idea that pseudo randomness
makes being said a hard problem to
distinguish the output of a
pseudo-random generator from a truly
random output okay so so then so that
begs the question though where do we get
this generator G from so our goal now is
to come up with a Jenner you know so we
want to prove that from a generic worst
case hardness assumption we can mold
that hardness problem that hard problem
into this the form of a veggie random is
distinguishing problem for a suitable
Chi so that's where the work goes in in
the what's called the hardness versus
randomness or hardness to randomness
like I don't know what to call it it's
not really an area but paradigm thank
you
okay so um so let's say the there's like
a traditional approach and there is
there other approaches I'm going to sort
of like just present the traditional
approach and and because and then say
why not only is the final result
interesting but every step of this
traditional approach is and it is in
itself an interesting combinatorial
problem that you'd be interested in even
if you don't didn't care about
randomness or well if you did care about
this particular form of randomness so
okay so what we're trying so what are
what are what is our general goal at
this point I want to have like several
parallel boards so I think I'm going to
erase everything at this point if it's
okay
so we're going to start with some
boolean function
f then I'm going to call F worse case so
and what will know about f worst case is
that this is going to be some function
from 0 1 to the N worst case 201 so just
a boolean function on this number of
bits I'm going to keep everything
concrete yes we're going to be dealing
with asymptotics at some point okay but
and what will know is that the size the
minimum circuit size that computes this
is at least some number a sub worst case
so keeping things totally generic okay
so this is this i'm using to mean the
minimum circuit that actually solves
this problem the number of gates of the
minimum circuit that solves a problem
and what we want to do eventually put in
a couple of intermediate steps but we
want to do is is eventually come up with
can people if i write this low can
people see the board okay so come up
with this generator G so that so it's
going to be on map n sub key bits two
key bits and we want to say that if at
this is hard then the the G randomness
distinguishing problem is a subkey hard
off with with the fifty five percent
success rate that we use as our
criterion so this is no circuit of less
than this size can solve this
oh and actually we want this to be also
be about tea because remember the inputs
to the circuit is maybe going to be
around the circuit sighs okay kisses
circuit or at least the number of inputs
to the circuit balance the circus sighs
so you think about this hardness that we
want left to be about the same as the
output for our generator what we want to
do this kind of constructively so what
that really means is that if we're given
a circuit see and this is you think of
as the input on which our algorithm
fails then and it is less than f sub G
size then given that that circuit that
distinguishes successfully distinguishes
the G random is distinguishing problem
successfully solves it then
putting some room for intermediate
concepts in the middle we should be able
to solve you know use this to construct
so let's call this C sub G for a circuit
that breaks the generator we should be
able to construct from that C sub worst
case that solves a problem and have C
sub worst case the size last hand the
the assumed worst-case complexity of the
function so what every step every every
we want this connection to be
constructive from any apps of worst case
in fact I'm going to put the the
function that we start with think of
that as being as determining the
generator so also think of this map as
for every function that determines a
generator from that function and and you
know maybe this assumption is true and
maybe it's not but the implication
should be true so that means that if he
isn't hard if we're given a
distinguisher then we should be able to
construct a circuit from that
distinguisher that solves the original
function in the worst case this is this
sort of high-level thing while we're
we're trying to the right column is just
the contrapositive left
is that like in some sense here yeah
it's just a contrapositive of the left
okay but I want to say that that we're
going to be talking about you know
what's also going to be important is not
only that these things exist or don't
exist but that we can actually construct
them that we're going to be given
explicit recipes to construct them now
here we're dealing essentially in the
non-uniform model so when I say we're
given explicit recipes then what we're
allowed to do is you know in going
backwards we're allowed to flip random
bits because we can simulate random bits
ran make random choices simulate that is
hardwired into our circuit and we're
also allowed some kinds of advice that
tell us some information out of advice
that we could hardwired into the circuit
so this backwards direction may not be
completely deterministically computable
from the circuit we may need some
information about our function in
particular to go in the backwards
direction okay so i think i
over-promised a little while ago so i
don't think i'm going to make it to let
me try to like see how much i can tell
you and then i may not like actually say
why the the the moderate position is
ridiculous has been rolled out okay so
um so we can look at the same thing so
Luca Trevisan
actually had the the following amazing
insight say well we can look at this
diagram just combinatorially what are we
actually doing here okay what what is
the combinatorial problem we need to go
from a function to a generator and then
from then be able to co from a circuit
that breaks that generator to the worst
case circuit that computes the function
he said if you view this comet aw really
this is a randomness extractor so I have
to make a digression here what is a
randomness extractor a randomness
extractor is a function
II so that it has two kinds of inputs it
has a a sorry I'm going to call it two
kinds of inputs let's call this capital
left and this i'm going to call X and we
can think in our our pic here as capital
F is going to correspond to this little
worst-case function little F and X is
going to correspond to the seed that
we're using for our generate to map our
generator into a cheapest train so it's
a so this is called the the seed and
this is called the input and you think
of the input is coming from a flawed
random
source which means is it's coming from
the uniform distribution the simplest
way to think of is coming from a uniform
distribution on a set script s of where
the size of script s is at least two to
the little s okay and this little ass is
going to have something to do with the
size bound over there and X on the other
hand is picked truly at random is a
truly random and bit string okay so this
is this F might be a much larger
stringing in general it will be much
larger than two to the then then little
s but it has some randomness and we want
to say is that whenever this is true
that this is very close to a uniform
string on T bits
how does the construction of a generator
give us an extractor the connection that
that Luca said is let's take the F F is
a string and you can view it as the
truth table for a boolean function let's
take the construction of the generator
relative to that boolean function that's
coded by the string f and see what
happens on seed x ok so let's
so comment or ially this extractor takes
f
to you know you think of plugging an F
the extractor takes f to a kind of
function from n bit strings to t bit
strings that's equivalent to the
generator and we want to say that if
this if this if this extracted if the if
the strings here are not random if they
have some property P then F wasn't
random
and if you look at what huh what what we
get from this this construction is that
if our if we use property P where the
extractor fails to have that's a way in
which the extracted bits are not random
we think of that as the circus C sub P
and then with a small amount of
additional advice a small amount of
additional information about F we can
construct a circuit we can decode f so
with this property that fails and a
small amount of additional information
about F then we know exactly what F is
okay and in particular that says that
gives a quantitative bound on how many
functions this generator isn't random on
and so that says for any source with
many more outputs than that number the
extractor is going to be random so here
here's an example waving my hands
vigorously so well the taluka said is
basically that any any any way of
filling in this diagram also gives you
this kind of really good randomness
extractor okay and so that's what I've
motivated us to say the way to fill in
this diagram is to is to like make a
read of this extractor that is sort of
local little compute ibly local it also
actually led to progress on new
constructions of randomness extractors
based on hardness to randomness
constructions that already existed okay
and if you look at what
what so how did how did how do we fill
what are the steps we use to go from
this hard function to a generator so the
first couple of steps are our this
function is just hard in the worst case
so the first kind of steps is to make to
go from a function that's hard in the
worst case to a function that's
quantitatively hard to solve because
this is like a as people pointed out we
need like a failure probability here for
this this so it's not just enough that
that we can't perfectly distinguish
random outputs from just determine the
range of G we have to have some
quantitative notion of failure so the
first few steps are to make our to make
this function make a version of this
function that that doesn't just have
worst-case hardness but has harness more
reliably so the first step is to go from
f worse case to a function that I'll
call F somewhat hard it's also adjust a
boolean function somewhat hard to 01 and
so then we say that the size say of
solving this problem point 9 of the time
is related is is still relatively large
so here I mean this any circuit solves
the somewhat hard problem if it's
correct on ninety percent of the inputs
okay okay and so that what that means
here is in the reverse direction if we
have a circuit that solves the problem
ninety percent of the time we need to
come up with a circuit that solves F
almost all the time okay then from this
we create sort of natural you know what
we create is a function that's hard not
just some fraction of the time but it's
almost indistinguishable from a random
bit okay so a very hard is of is has
size a half plus about the one and T
that we're shooting for so the advantage
in computing so here we're looking at a
circuit that just gets the answer right
on slightly more than the more inputs
and it gets the answer wrong if that's
bigger than some related size s th and
this is going to be
on some number of bits n vh ok and again
what this means in the reverse direction
is we have to go from a circuit that's
very hard to a circuit that somewhat
hard using a certain amount of
randomness in a certain amount of advice
and not very much of either so um if you
could slice through any drugs on this
well the randomness could be advice
there's a reason I want to distinguish
the two but that reason is probably
obsolete because I'm not going to have
time to to talk about talk about why
it's interesting okay so I want to say
that I may not have time to fill in any
of these steps how they're actually
constructed they're all very interesting
but when we say that each of these once
years are a little bit live in the post
Luca world we sort of like look for what
were the combinatorial analogs of these
things and say every step is really
interesting comet orioli and so let me
try to explain what each step means
combinatorially and say that in that
actually once you see that if you're
familiar with some of the coding theory
constructions then you could sort of
guess how we're going to do it in the in
the in the randomness to to hardness
hardness to randomness okay so and ok so
what are we doing in this first step we
want to go from a problem that's hard in
the worst case to a problem that's hard
a good fraction of the inputs we can
think of that as a kind of coding
problem we're trying to code this
worst-case hard problem by this somewhat
hard problem in a way that's more robust
that
if we don't have all the answers for the
somewhat hard problem that still
determines the answers for the worst
case heart problem so if you think about
it in terms of this going backwards we
need a to go from something a circuit
that gets the right answer most of the
time so it's kind of like a noisy
version of this function the circuit
gives you a noisy version of this
function to exactly recovering the
original function so that's the sort of
analogy would lead you to error
correcting codes so an error correcting
code is a way so we take a message I'm
going to call it capital F sub worst
case and we have a code that produces
some longer string i'm going to call
capital F sub somewhat hard and and then
we send this a longer string through
some noisy channel and we get some
received bed received message that i'm
going to call see somewhat hard by being
being very leading and what's see
somewhat hard is the relative hamming
distance between see somewhat hard and f
somewhat hard we know is going to be
small relatively small so here I'm like
normalizing by the length of the two
strings and then
in the decoding process once we receive
this
we take see somewhat hard and we have to
produce our guess as to what the
original function was and if everything
is working these two perfectly match up
so error correcting code has the
property that whenever the relative
Hamming distance between the received
word and the sent word is then the
decoding algorithm exactly recovers this
if you think about this square that's
exactly what we want yes and we need it
to be for our purposes we also need it
to be locally decodable it's not enough
so what is what's important is that we
can define see this in low complexity
with an Oracle for this so if we look at
this so we're given a circuit here
rather than explicit message so that
allows us to evaluate any particular bit
of this and we need to be able to
evaluate any any pretty great bit of
this so this diagram is exactly a
locally decodable error correcting code
and once you see that that's what we
want is kind of natural to say what what
is our this is not historically how it
happened but what is our you know to go
to our our repertoire of locally
decodable error correcting codes and say
what are what's available and there's
only like two like there's read miller
codes and Reese all reet Solomon codes
so I know and I can't remember which is
worth which so so I'm just going to say
it's a read molar Solomon code okay and
so mean mower Sullivan code if you look
at it in terms it actually is a is
really natural to think about that in
terms of boolean functions because what
is the Reed moment Solomon code you take
your message you view it as the truth
table for a boolean function you embed
that boolean function or interpolate
that boolean function inside
a small degree function
over
a moderate-sized yield
so well we we end up with is you know
this miss our our our new somewhat hard
function is basically a function that's
loaded that's defined over a finite
field where it agrees with the original
function when the inputs are boolean and
it's low degree in each of these why
eyes and it's easy to see that any
boolean function embeds in a number of
ways into such algebraic functions over
the field and then the decoding
algorithm the local decoding algorithm
then looked at you know it's basically
the idea was looked at by beaver and
Feigenbaum by Lipton and using a number
of other contexts yes in this context it
was first introduced bye bye bye for now
nasaan and wigs Orson what you do is you
take you think of this function is being
defined over a large dimensional space
but you restrict the function to a line
and you make some you that contains the
point that you want to evaluate the
function on its you have a ok and then
you evaluate the function on the line
you ignore using using whatever Oracle
you're given that approximates this
function and hope that it agrees with a
function on every point on this line if
so your interpolation is valid and
you're the point that you really want to
know is valid and the main point is that
actually the other point on this line
individually are independent of the
point that you start with because
there's for any point here at any point
in space there's exactly one line that
goes between them waving hands
vigorously ok and this is really also
the known algorithm for for decoding
you know that that's been used in
decoding it's not necessarily boolean so
you have to do some work to make it
boolean again which i'm going to call so
it's not necessarily bullion let's
ignore that yes actually so the whole
point is that in this step all you need
to decode is randomness there is no
actually other no actual other advice
needed so this one use some randomness
and it has a little bit of time but it
doesn't actually add any there's no real
advice needed and the reason that that's
true in terms of coding is and not going
to be true for in the next step is that
in this regime these codes are uniquely
decodable and their limits on how much
you can you can actually do this with
with a decoding algorithm that just
returned is one possibility however if
you weaken the if you weaken the
criterion I know I'm going a little late
okay then you could define a list
decodable code and a list decodable code
doesn't I'll put one string it outputs a
whole list of strings
and the function you know these are all
guesses for what this function what the
input was and one of the gases is
correct with high probability ok the
other thing though is we've already done
this step so the problem okay so can we
go back to this picture for a second
okay what is the price we pay in this
picture we had a really nice decoding
algorithm the price we pay is that our
encoding algorithm is not so nice it's
polynomial time computable and you can
put it in some smaller classes like NC 1
okay but you can't get it down to two
there's no local encoding or even any
kind of encoding in the polynomial time
hierarchy in the in the AC 0 i should
say which would correspond to what that
means is that if F sub what W case is
exponential time this function will
still be exponential time if it's
polynomial space this function will be
polynomial space but if it's NP this
will be polynomial space there's no
there's no real complexity preserving
reduction at this point in particular
you can't do this with just or local
Oracle access to the input function so
this this part is actually global and
we're going to be able to make all the
other parts local and that's going to be
a technical distinction that comes up in
some results okay so that's like one
price we pay for the simplicity of the
decoding thank you but so one thing
though that to our benefit in the second
square is even though we are we're going
to have to move to list decoding because
actually there's no other
No DQ you know it's just combinatorially
impossible to have unique decoding from
this small very large amount of error we
don't actually have to have full
decoding what we can have because we've
already done this part it's enough to
get something that somewhat close to our
original function so we only need this
to be somewhat close so the second
square corresponds to approximate
I'm list decoding
okay so a proximate means that so
approximate local listing coding still
has to be local because we need to
actually construct the circuit from the
circuit its approximate in that the
message that week reconstruct only has
to approximately agree with the original
message and its list decoding in that
will come up with a number of
possibilities and actually the advice
here is going to be the log of the
number of possible the log of the the
list size it's going to be kind of
inherent advice that can't be random
okay so okay so the second step
corresponds to approximate local list
seco ting which is kind of interesting
especially since you can do this is a
good actually of you know composing
these two steps is a good way of making
lists decodable codes and local bus
decoding approximate list decoding can
be done even locally defining your your
encoding function as well as locally
defining your decoding function and sort
of the what these look like is just you
take a bunch of bits and you explore
them together okay or you use the X for
construction on the function and then
finally we can view this last step comet
aw really as a kind of randomness
extractor
again that's sort of not saving us a lot
over the whole square how you know what
did going through these first few steps
give us we say there's a whole square is
a randomness extractor but a random the
extractor from sources where I fo x is
approximately uniform so that means most
bits look already look you know so that
so I'll call these on from randomness
smooth
sources sources where most bits are
already are already high entropy and
there's some kind of global entropy and
here we also need some it some non
redness advice but I I think I'm totally
out of time ok so but even though I'm
out of time now we've gone through all
this work let me just like summarize a
few things that we we actually get from
looking at this somebody sort of looking
at things comet orally finding the the
optimal constructions for each part in
different ranges of parameters we can
prove the following kinds of theorems so
so this is like ba bye for now nasaan
and lincocin so if there exists so like
if X is not contained at p / poly then
promised bpp is contained in time
through monistic time to to the end to
the epsilon for every epsilon so this is
called a low end d randomization because
we're making us a relatively small
assumption about the worst-case
complexity of polynomial time of
exponential time complete comprar bombs
and get by getting them relatively mild
consequence here and I guess I should
also say infinitely often a high end
version says if there exists f in X in E
which is time to to the order and rather
than to to the entity to the K server
sighs of F is greater than 2 to the
Delta and for some fixed delta greater
than zero then promise equals P so then
you get full d randomization from a
suitably from a stronger assumption here
I'm seeing here I'm implicitly saying
that this holds for every n which is
here this was implicitly saying this
holds infinitely often which is why you
get infinitely often here and and
everywhere here then one other result
that I wanted to mention today that just
because I imagine I sort of implicitly
mentioned it why the moderate position
is is not write another paper of mine
and avi shows that if X is different
from bpp then promised bpp is in
heuristic heuristic deterministic time
the entity epsilon
what this means is that while there
might be a few instances on which the
algorithm fails you can't read there so
few that it's actually an intractable
problem to find any so if B this would
you know if XP for equal to B PP this
would say that every hard problem is
randomness helps so that would be a very
extreme position and then this says that
if not then the problems on which
randomness helps our helps exponentially
by the most amount possible are are
negligible only very rare for every
problem so you can't have sometimes some
problems randomness helps to the maximum
amount but it's not true for all
problems if there's any problem in which
random is helps reliably by a huge
amount then all then it helps a huge
amount for all problems
and all of these follow the same
paradigm okay I think I'll stop there
are there any implications that you'd
like to know that you don't know I'd
like to know that bpp is different from
at from like non sure mystic exponential
time implications so okay so I
quantitatively so there okay ve implies
fault yeah right so the sort of natural
worst-case to worst case you know the
woods natural most of the okay I mean
most of the picture has been kind of
filled in I guess if you go to two non
deterministic compute computing we know
fairly similar things but i'd like i'd
like to
yeah so like what I can't say the answer
without getting really technical next on
tomorrow's to lecture we're going to
talk about implications in the other
direction where you start with a generic
algorithm for cap and derive a circuit
lower bound from that and what what I'd
really like is if they became
equivalences and they don't quite most
of the time but the reason they don't
they're not equivalences it's kind of
technical has to do with like it's
infinitely often here in the everywhere
there valentin can you think of like
some yeah that would be good yeah in
fact yeah that's so these work for a
broad you know I phrase it in terms of
arbitrary classes circuits you know
arbitrary circuits we could also look at
the same thing for subclasses of
circuits and if we do think you know if
we do things like subclasses of circuits
like NC one most things work because
they're closed under natural functions
and clothes under like polynomial time
blow up but if you try to do things
quantitatively said what kind of result
do we get if we have a super linear
circuit lower bound do we get any kind
of D randomization that would be a great
result right now I don't I don't see how
we get even even any non-trivial d
randomization if we say proven N squared
lower bound
so look at this in a more fine-grain
hick